around seven and a half million people
have now had their first dose of the
kovid jab
more than four out of five of everyone
over the age of 80
and many will have had the oxford
vaccine
but german medical authorities now say
it shouldn't be given to those over 65
because of a lack of evidence that it
prevents the disease
mike is 71 and has just been vaccinated
his confidence is unshaken i'm perfectly
reassured
by what i've heard from everybody and
particularly my own doctor who
has looked into it and said you're
absolutely
fine having this backseat germany is
fighting its own
surge in cases but its public health
body the robert koch institute
has jumped in even before the european
medicines regulator has ruled on the
vaccine safety and efficacy
and warned against using it in the
elderly without better evidence that it
protects them
german scientists agree the pfizer jab
is a good alternative
in this situation where obviously the
doubts are
are there i guess having an alternative
an eternal vaccine that has been
shown in the trial to work in this group
so i think it's a reasonable decision
to say well we'll use the functioning
vaccine of which we are at least more
sure than
this vaccine now the prime minister
visiting another pharmaceutical company
dismissed the concerns i think that the
mhra our own authorities have made it
very clear that they
think the oxford astrozenica vaccine is
very good and efficacious
gives a high degree of protection after
just one dose and even more after after
two doses
there is a gap in the evidence just four
percent of the volunteers in the key
clinical trials were over the age of 70
and there weren't enough cases of covid
to prove the vaccine protected
more people than the placebo but lab
tests show that
older people produce just as many
virus-killing antibodies
in response to the jab as the young that
was good enough for the uk medicines
authority
and this former drug regulator age 77
and another recipient of the vaccine i
not only believe that i'm protected
i believe that anybody who has had the
oxford astrazeneca
and who is aged over 70 will also be
protected
but none of us will be protected
perfectly another clinical trial of the
oxford jab with more
older volunteers is currently underway
in the united states
in the meantime uk scientists are
confident in the rollout
with such a high infection rate they
believe the vaccine
will save lives thomas more sky news